north korea claims it successfully
test-fired a new type of nuclear missile
over the weekend just before the united
states and south korea began a joint
military exercise the north's official
news agency released a photo claiming
the show dictator kim jong-un
celebrating the test elizabeth palmer
has more from tokyo
good morning
this is the 12th missile test in three
and a half months and proof that north
korea's leader kim jong-un is fast
tracking a serious upgrade to his
already fearsome arsenal
official north korean pictures show the
launch of what south korean analysts say
were two short-range missiles at least
one of which landed on a tiny rocky
island kim jong-un is among the
observers looking especially pleased
we've seen variations of this the
launches and the happy leader every few
weeks since january they may have a
cartoon quality but they're deadly
serious
on friday there was a huge parade in
pyongyang on a public holiday to mark
the 110th anniversary of the birth of
north korea's founder kim il-sung
unusually the only weapons on show were
neon lit models but behind the spectacle
preparations were already underway for
the very real weapons test with ominous
overtones it's not the hardware that's
got alarm bells ringing this time so
much as the rhetoric the north koreans
are saying the missile is meant to carry
nuclear warheads which it already has
and analysts think we'll be seeing a new
nuclear test sometime very soon
for cbs mornings elizabeth palmer tokyo